joe i got a couple questions for you
what's your favorite cereal of all time
um
maybe uh captain crunch
me too yeah but
bury a regular
um
i think regular
barry's cool too i'm not mad if you got
buried
[Laughter]
you know
isn't there a peanut butter captain
question
i think i would always go for that yeah
i'm a peanut butter fiend i like peanut
butter what's your favorite cartoon of
all time
oh
man
i guess
i guess bugs bunny
bugs bunny yeah because i grew up with
that what's up doc like when i was a kid
bugs bunny was full of action a lot of
[ __ ] was happening people were getting
shot in the face i liked the rabbit
kicked the butt the rabbit kicked the
bucket the wavy kick the
i mean it was a hunter that i was always
literally trying to kill bugs bunny and
he was so clever that he was relaxed
uh no that was uh elmer fudd and
refurbished
the hunter yeah elmer phil was the dumb
[ __ ] with he was the gun guy
yeah he always gets shot in his own
face his face would be covered in
gunpowder but
it's rabbit season do you know that
that's what the gun community calls
people that only buy guns for hunting
they call them fuds for real yeah
because the gun community is filled with
gun dorks
and they only respect you if you're like
super hardcore knowledgeable about gun
[ __ ] like velocity and yeah like what do
you hunt elk with 300 win mag
they have like how many grains of
[ __ ] is your bullets and
so when people don't care about that
they call them fuds
amber's nephews even in the world of
guns people turn on each other
they call each other names would you
expect
but there's too many guns in america so
this the strategy has got to be let's
get everybody to be more polite more
trained
more responsible
have it for protection if needed yeah
walks off and carry a big stick that's
usually what i do
[Music]